This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档iHeart播客节目。确保是真人。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个陌生的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加英文“percent”，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是重要的一刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，回顾当时的发生过的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。多少男人穿着一副铠甲。它向全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的检测结果篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听播客节目《Love Trapped》。大家好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨二十几岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode, back for another topic. Today, I think we're going to tackle a very important question in the self-help space. One that I think has been coming, up a lot more, but is also the source of a lot of criticism. And the question is, is it possible to be too self-aware? I have been thinking about this personally for a while, particularly as someone who has a lot to do, obviously, with the self-help and the mental health space. And I really do love it. I have no complaints. It is the thing I love most in the world. But the one thing that I do sometimes
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听新的一集，探讨新的主题。今天，我认为我们要探讨自我提升领域中一个非常重要的问题。这个问题我觉得最近被提及得越来越多了，但它也是大量批评的来源。这个问题就是：一个人有可能过于自我觉察吗？我个人思考这个问题已经有一段时间了，特别是作为一个与自我提升和心理健康领域密切相关的人。我真的很喜欢它。我没有任何抱怨。这是我这辈子最热爱的事情。但我偶尔确实发现的一件事是
find really draining is this tendency and sometimes this need to be constantly assessing and analyzing my own emotions and contemplating all the psychological and internal explanations for my behaviour, you know, week after week. And I think at times that has left me quite mentally burnt out and perhaps thinking that maybe as humans, we are not meant to be constantly thinking about how we feel who we are or our others perceive us. And yet I think our increasing acknowledgement of our emotions and our mental state is so beneficial. It's done wonders for how we treat ourselves. We are so much more gentle and kind to ourselves these days and very much aware of the people we are, of who we are becoming. But at what point is that self-reflection and contemplation
让人感到精疲力竭的是这种倾向，有时也是一种需求，即周复一周地不断评估和分析自己的情绪，思考我行为背后的所有心理和内在解释。我想有时这让我精神上相当筋疲力竭，甚至让我觉得也许作为人类，我们本不该一直去想我们的感受、我们是谁，或者别人是如何看待我们的。然而，我认为我们对情绪和心理状态日益增强的认知是非常有益的。它对我们对待自己的方式产生了奇妙的效果。如今，我们对自己要温和、善良得多，并且非常清楚我们是什么样的人，我们正在成为谁。但在什么时候，这种反思和沉思
too much. At what point can that become even harmful to some extent? So that is really what I want to discuss today. That's what I want to dive into. Let's start at the basics, though. What exactly is self-awareness and why is it such, I guess, a celebrated trait in our idea in our society? Something that I would say a lot of us who consume self-help content are striving towards. Self-awareness from a very bird's eye view is essentially our ability to understand our ourselves and align our emotions, our thoughts, actions, desires, beliefs, and values, align them all together. It's almost about having an objective view of who we are, why we are that way, and how we want our future selves to be. You know, for example, it's about understanding what
就过头了。在什么时候，这种状态甚至会在某种程度上变得有害呢？这正是今天我想讨论的内容。这也是我想深入探讨的话题。不过，让我们从基础开始。究竟什么是自我觉察？为什么它在我们社会的理念中是一个如此备受赞誉的特质？我想说，我们当中许多消费自我提升内容的人都在朝着这个方向努力。从一个非常宏观的视角来看，自我觉察本质上是我们理解自己，并将我们的情绪、思想、行动、欲望、信念和价值观融会贯通、保持一致的能力。这几乎就像是对我们是谁、我们为什么会这样，以及我们希望未来的自己成为什么样的人，拥有一个客观的看法。你知道，举个例子，它关乎理解你
maybe you are and you are not good at or how you act in front of certain people, recognizing when something upsets you and why that might be knowing what motivates you, knowing why you think a certain way. All of these things, all of these qualities of being someone who has high self-awareness, are really healthy and they're really positive. I think it means that we are not left feeling confused about our behavior or alienated from ourselves because we feel very aligned and very stable in who we are. I think there's also this very deep belief in our society. that by understanding ourselves, we can live a better and more meaningful life. And I do think that that is quite true, because I don't think there is anyone who is going to stand up and say that
擅长什么、不擅长什么，或者你在某些人面前如何表现，认识到什么时候某件事让你心烦意乱以及原因可能是什么，知道是什么在激励着你，知道你为什么会有某种想法。所有这些事情，所有这些拥有高自我觉察之人的特质，都是非常健康且非常积极的。我认为这意味着我们不会对自己的行为感到困惑，也不会与自己产生疏离感，因为我们在“我是谁”这一点上感到非常一致且非常稳定。我认为我们的社会中也存在着一种根深蒂固的信念：通过了解自己，我们可以过上更好、更有意义的生活。而且我认为这确实相当正确，因为我认为没有人会站出来说
self-awareness isn't something that is incredibly positive. And that's because scientifically, psychologically, it does have so many benefits. There's been a lot of research on this, especially in recent years and in positive and organizational psychology. And according to the Harvard Business Review, most of it, the majority of it suggests that when we see ourselves clearly, we are more confident, we are more creative, we make better decisions, we build stronger relationships, and we communicate more effectively. We're also less likely to do things that are seen as maybe immoral, illegal, or counterproductive or antisocial. So things like lying, cheating, stealing. And I guess we also just
自我觉察不是一件极其积极的事情。这是因为从科学和心理学角度来看，它确实有太多的好处。这方面有很多研究，特别是在近年来以及积极心理学和组织心理学领域。根据《哈佛商业评论》的说法，大部分，也就是绝大多数研究表明，当我们能够清晰地认识自己时，我们会更加自信、更富有创造力，能做出更好的决策，建立更牢固的人际关系，并且沟通更有效。我们也更不容易做出那些被认为是不道德、违法、适得其反或反社会的行为。比如撒谎、作弊、偷窃。我想我们也只是
feel generally more content because it's in this psychological state whereby our self is the focus of our intention that we can really dig into things that are bothering us and we can look critically at our lives and our surroundings for solutions. And that self-awareness, that thing that we all really want, we all really are striving for, it's really something that we start developing quite early on at around 18 months or so. That is when we first see signs. of self-awareness, we're able to identify ourselves in a mirror, and then by four to five, we develop self-consciousness, and we're aware of the idea that we can be perceived by others, and that we in turn can perceive them. I think that development is both a blessing and a curse
普遍感觉更加满足，因为正是在这种将自我作为注意力焦点的心理状态下，我们才能真正深入探讨那些困扰我们的事情，并能为了寻找解决方案而批判性地审视我们的生活和周围环境。而这种自我觉察，也就是我们所有人都真正渴望、都在努力追求的东西，其实是我们很早就开始培养的一种能力，大约在18个月左右。那是我们第一次看到自我觉察的迹象，我们能够在镜子中认出自己，然后在四到五岁时，我们发展出了自我意识，并意识到这样一个概念：我们能被他人感知，而我们反过来也能感知他们。我认为这种发展既是福也是祸，
in many ways, as we'll discuss later, because although that is normally the time when we begin to really behave within social convention, we start to see that our actions have cause and effect. It's also at this stage where we begin to experience things like shame and embarrassment. And if that is left unchecked, that can create a lot of insecurities that stay with us into adulthood. The other important thing to know about self-awareness is also that it can be divided into two distinct types or versions. We have our public self-awareness, also known as external self-awareness, and then our private or internal self-awareness. So public self-awareness, as the name kind of suggests, it typically emerges in situations where we are around other people.
在许多方面，正如我们稍后将讨论的那样，因为虽然这通常是我们开始真正按照社会规范行事、开始看到我们的行动有因果关系的时候，但也是在这个阶段，我们开始经历诸如羞耻和尴尬之类的事情。如果不加控制，这可能会产生许多伴随我们进入成年期的不安全感。关于自我觉察，另一件重要的事情是，它可以分为两种截然不同的类型或版本。我们有公众自我觉察，也被称为外部自我觉察，然后是我们的私人或内部自我觉察。所以公众自我觉察，顾名思义，通常出现在我们身处其他人周围的社交情境中。
And we want to appear socially desirable, and we want to be accepted. It's the part of us that worries what other people think. And it's sometimes very, very hypervigilant towards social cues that other people might be putting out that maybe they don't like us or that we're behaving strangely or that we need to be doing a certain thing to fit in. Then we have our private self-awareness, which is basically kind of what we've been talking about so far. It's where we are aware of something about ourselves, maybe our feelings or our attitudes, our cognitions, in a manner that is quite private, that people from the outside can't really judge or get into. It's really our ability to introspect. It's our ability to
并且我们希望显得在社交上令人向往，并渴望被接纳。这是我们担心别人怎么想的那一部分。有时它对其他人可能不喜欢我们、我们表现得很奇怪或者我们需要做某事来融入集体的社交线索表现得非常、非常高度警惕。然后我们有私人自我觉察，这基本上有点像我们到目前为止一直在谈论的内容。在这种状态下，我们以一种非常私密的方式意识到关于自己的某些事情，也许是我们的感受、态度、认知，这是外部的人无法真正评判或介入的。这确实是我们内省的能力。这是我们的能力
put ourselves in front of an internal mirror. But interestingly, it's actually a combination of public and private self-awareness that seems to give us the greatest level of self-consciousness, and not self-consciousness in the sense that you feel insecure, but self-consciousness in that you know yourself and you know yourself well. I'm going to say this. I think with most things that we talk about on this podcast in psychology in general, self-awareness is a spectrum. It exists on a spectrum. There are some people who can give you a very logical reason for their every action. They understand exactly how they tick. What motivates them? Why they behave the way they do. All of their flaws. They pathologize. They intellectualize everything. And then on the other
把自己放在一面内在的镜子前。但有趣的是，实际上正是公众和私人自我觉察的结合，似乎赋予了我们最高水平的自我意识——这里的自我意识不是指你感到不安全意义上的自我意识，而是指你了解自己并且非常了解自己的那种自我意识。我想说的是：我认为就像我们在本播客中和一般的心理学中讨论的大多数事情一样，自我觉察是一个光谱。它存在于一个光谱上。有些人能为他们的每一个行动提供一个非常合乎逻辑的理由。他们确切地了解自己的运作方式。是什么在激励着他们？他们为什么会有这样的行为。他们所有的缺点。他们将一切病理化、知识化。而在另一端
is this other category of people who do things really without having a reason or an explanation. They can't really explain why they feel a certain way or why they do something a certain way or who they kind of truly are at their core. People who lack self-awareness, they also typically are pretty low in empathy as well. And that's not always the case. but I do think that there is this group of people who we kind of observe in public who just seemed completely unaware that other people exist. And I saw this TikTok the other day that I thought really represented this. And it was this girl kind of holding up a line of, I would say, 20 or 30 people.
则是另一类人，他们做事真的没有理由或解释。他们无法真正解释为什么自己会有某种感觉，或者为什么以某种方式做某事，或者他们在核心上究竟是谁。缺乏自我觉察的人，通常同理心也相当低。虽然并非总是如此。但我确实认为，有一群人在公众场合中我们能观察到，他们似乎完全没有意识到其他人的存在。我前几天刷到一个TikTok视频，我觉得非常能代表这一点。视频里是一个女孩挡住了我估计有20或30人的队伍。
And she was taking a photo at an art gallery. And she just seemed so unaware that there were all of these other people who were waiting in the line behind her for 10, 15, 20 minutes. that is the kind of individual that we're looking at here when we're talking about specifically low public awareness, but it also links to low private awareness as well. And the reason people like this exist is because they are so unaware of their own emotions and feelings what might make them feel annoyed or frustrated or angry that they are unable to really see how their own behavior might create similar feelings within others. For people who possess minimal self-awareness, honestly, sometimes I think it would be nice to never have to
她当时正在艺术馆里拍照。她似乎完全没有意识到，身后还有所有这些其他人已经在队伍里等了10、15、20分钟。当我们专门谈论低公众觉察时，我们所看的就是这种类型的个人，但它其实也与低私人觉察相连。之所以存在这样的人，是因为他们对自己的情绪和感觉——是什么让他们感到恼火、沮丧或愤怒——如此缺乏觉察，以至于他们无法真正看到自己的行为如何在他人身上产生类似的情绪。对于那些几乎没有自我觉察的人来说，老实说，有时我想不用再去想别人是如何看待你的，因公众形象而产生的不安全感更少，或者不必识别每一种情绪而只是去感受它，这倒挺不错的。但同时这些个人，我认为，这是一个平衡，他们往往在其他方面苦苦挣扎。他们会有更多的人际冲突，因为他们没有意识到其他人的情绪状态。他们做出的选择更糟糕。他们经常难以自我纠正或承担责任。但也许最关键的是，他们的情绪在某种程度上控制了他们。现在我想把话题转向光谱的另一端，深入探讨我们今天的核心问题。有可能
think about how other people see you, to have fewer insecurities based on your public image, or to not have to identify every emotion, but just feel it. But also these individuals, I think, you know, it's a balance and often they struggle in other ways. They have more personal conflict because they are not aware of other people's emotional states. They make poorer choices. They often have trouble self-correcting or accepting responsibility. But perhaps most crucially, their emotions somewhat control them. I want to shift to the other end of the spectrum now and really dig into that primary question that we have for today. Is it possible? to be too self-aware. I think the answer is already pretty clear, but yes, I really do think it's
过于自我觉察吗？我想答案已经相当明显了，是的，我真的认为有可能
possible to be almost too conscious of what we're feeling to the point of encountering some pretty counterproductive tendencies, like perfectionism, overthinking, indecisiveness, intense self-consciousness, even loneliness to some extent. It's also this strange paradox whereby the more we attempt to know ourselves, the more we can start to feel detached, because our actions and emotions, they no longer really feel like they're coming from us, but from some outside external force that we're watching and observing. Some people argue that at this point, we're kind of no longer actually experiencing self-awareness, but self-evaluation or self-obsession.
对自己的感受过于敏感，以至于陷入一些相当适得其反的倾向，比如完美主义、过度思考、优柔寡断、强烈的自我意识，甚至在某种程度上感到孤独。这也是一个奇怪的悖论：我们越是试图了解自己，就越开始感到超脱，因为我们的行动和情绪不再真正觉得是来自我们自己，而是来自某种我们在注视和观察的外部力量。有些人认为，在这一点上，我们其实不再是在经历自我觉察，而是在进行自我评估或自我迷恋。
However, I do think that it's different, right? I think that the primary goal that results on us getting to this point is wanting to know ourselves better, but then it does start to almost look like self-obsession because we can no longer control how much we are reflecting and introspecting. So if you're someone who really doesn't remember the last time you felt like there wasn't something you needed to work on or improve about yourself or who ruminates on every social interaction, maybe you have gotten to the point of rationalizing every emotional response or really considering every word you say to others or every slight gesture. I think that's a sign that your efforts to know yourself better are actually separating you more from your authentic self, that they may have become, as I would say in psychology, maladaptive. The crucial point to make is that too much of a good thing
然而，我认为这是不同的，对吧？我认为导致我们达到这一点的首要目标是想要更好地了解自己，但它确实开始看起来像自我迷恋，因为我们再也无法控制自己反思和内省的程度。所以如果你是一个真的记不清上一次觉得自己没有什么需要努力或改进的地方是在什么时候的人，或者是一个对每一次社交互动都反复琢磨的人，也许你已经到了将每一种情绪反应都合理化，或者真正仔细斟酌你对别人说的每一句话或每一个微小手势的地步。我认为这是一个迹象，表明你更好地了解自己的努力实际上正使你与真实的自我进一步分离，用心理学的话说，它们可能已经变得“适应不良”。至关重要的一点是，好事过头
can still be harmful. And I think we see that here. We see that in this circumstance. I think also we kind of fall into this trap when this is our pattern of thought, when we are becoming consumed with analyzing rather than feeling our emotions or looking for answers or really trying to problem solve every single thing that we're feeling. Firstly, we're kind of faced with a lot of chronic indecisiveness, but also the inability to focus on our responsibilities, not actually feeling like we know who we are and a failure to really see the bigger picture, which at times is going to create social anxiety, like we said before, it's going to make it harder to make decisions, but also that self-absorption.
仍然可能有害。我想我们在这一点上看到了这一点，在这种情况看到了这一点。我还认为，当我们有这种思维模式时，当我们全神贯注于分析而不是感受情绪，或者试图寻找答案、真正试图对我们感受到的每一件事都进行问题解决时，我们就会陷入这个陷阱。首先，我们面临着许多慢性的优柔寡断，还有无法专注于自己的责任、实际上并不觉得了解自己，以及未能真正看到更宏大的图景，而这有时会产生我们之前说的社交焦虑，它会使做决定变得更加困难，同时也会带来这种自我吸收。
And like I said before, I don't necessarily think that is the case because a lot of the time when we overthink or over-analyze, we're actually worried more about the reactions or feelings of others. But when we spend too much time in our own thoughts, sometimes it can be hard to get the perspective you need to make the right decisions, the perspective that, you know, maybe not everyone really cares all that much and that you're doing or making choices for people who don't matter because you are to a self-aware, be self-conscious. And I think it's kind of like this spectrum of low to high awareness in which it's shaped like a horseshoe. So being at either end of the extreme kind of results in the same outcomes here.
就像我之前说的，我不认为情况必然如此，因为很多时候当我们过度思考或过度分析时，我们其实更担心的是他人的反应或感受。但当我们花太多时间在自己的思想中时，有时很难获得做出正确决定所需的视角，那种视角会让你意识到，你知道，可能并不是每个人都在乎那么多，而且你所做的事情或做出的选择是为了那些不重要的人，因为你过于自我觉察，过于自我意识。我想这有点像一个从低到高觉察的光谱，它的形状像一个马蹄铁。所以处于极端的任何一端，某种程度上都会导致这里相同的结局。
So having too little self-awareness and too much self-awareness is going to result in the same thing whereby we let our emotions control us or our thoughts control us more than they probably should. The other major sign of someone who is perhaps bordering on being a little bit too self-aware is that need to intellectualize or rationalize everything that they have. feeling. And although I think that might feel like we're working through our emotions or problem solving, when we find ourselves intellectualizing every experience or feeling like we have to understand everything that we're going through, we're actually separating ourselves from our emotions by putting
因此，自我觉察太少和自我觉察太多，最终会导致同样的事情，即我们任由情绪或思想控制自己，程度甚至超过了它们本应达到的水平。另一个可能有点接近过于自我觉察的人的主要迹象，就是需要将他们所经历的一切都知识化或合理化。虽然我觉得这可能感觉像是在梳理情绪或解决问题，但当我们发现自己将每一次经历都进行知识化，或者觉得必须理解我们正在经历的一切时，我们实际上是将自己与情绪隔离开来，在
up this barrier between us and the actual feeling. So an example I like to think of is heartbreak. we've all been heartbroken, we've all had our hearts absolutely shattered, and when we go through something like a breakup or a betrayal, or just the natural end of a long, meaningful relationship, we are going to feel a really intense range of human emotions. Heartbreak is such a profound experience, one that really cuts us deeply and causes a lot of real pain. And our instinct, as humans, as animals, is to avoid pain at any cost. Not just, physical but mental as well. So one way of doing that is by over rationalizing every little twinge and moment of sadness by saying, you know, okay, the reason I'm feeling sad right now is because of X, Y and Z.
我们与真实的感受之间竖起了这道屏障。我喜欢想到的一个例子是心碎。我们都经历过心碎，我们所有人都曾心碎得粉碎，当我们经历像分手、背叛或一段长久而有意义的关系自然走向终结这样的事情时，我们会感受到一系列强烈的人类情感。心碎是一种深刻的体验，它真正深深地刺痛我们，并带来许多真实的痛苦。而我们作为人类、作为动物的本能，是不惜一切代价避开痛苦。不仅是身体上的痛苦，还有心理上的痛苦。所以做到这一点的一种方法，就是通过将每一个微小的隐痛和悲伤时刻过度合理化，来说：“好吧，我此刻感到难过是因为X、Y和Z。
I felt bonded to this person. It's because of the biological addiction to the neurotransmitters that they released in my brain. And I know that that's going to wear off. And I know that the only reason I'm feeling sad is because I'm feeling lonely. For some people, that might make you feel better, right? But there's something really crucial missing here. And that is that at no point are you actually feeling that emotion. You are intellectualizing it almost as a subconscious form of avoidance, of emotional avoidance. And intellectualization, it does come from a place of very deep self-awareness. But it's also important to recognize that, like I said, before, it is a defense mechanism at the end of the day by which we use reasoning to prevent us from having to confront uncomfortable emotions. And some studies, including one conducted back
我曾与这个人产生羁绊。这是因为大脑中他们释放的神经递质产生的生物学成瘾。我知道这会消退。我知道我感到难过的唯一原因是我感到孤独。”对某些人来说，这可能会让你感觉好一些，对吧？但这里缺少了一些非常关键的东西。那就是在任何时候你其实都没有真正感受到那种情绪。你将它知识化了，这几乎成了逃避情绪的一种潜意识形式。而知识化确实源于非常深厚的自我觉察。但同样重要的是要认识到，就像我之前说的，归根结底它是一种防卫机制，我们用推理来阻止自己去面对不舒服的情绪。一些研究，包括2012年和2014年进行的
in 2012, one in 2014, they suggested that this act of intellectualizing our problems, our emotions, our feelings, that can be just as harmful as completely ignoring uncomfortable emotions altogether. that it can also make it really hard to live in the moment. And whilst I do sometimes think that living in the moment is a little bit overrated, and let's face it, very difficult if you're someone who is anxious, there is an important point to be made that when we spend too much time in our own minds and we get stuck in our own heads and thoughts, self-reflecting, introspecting, you're not going to be able to enjoy the present moment as much. And I'm sure many of us, if you're listening to this episode,
研究表明，这种将我们的问题、情绪和感觉知识化的行为，其危害可能与完全忽视令人不舒服的情绪一样大。它也确实会让人很难活在当下。虽然我有时确实认为活在当下有点被高估了，而且让我们面对现实吧，如果你是一个焦虑的人，这会非常困难，但有一点很重要：当我们花太多时间在自己的思想中，陷入自己的头脑和想法中无法自拔、进行自我反思和内省时，你就无法好好享受当下的时刻。我相信我们中的许多人，如果你正在听这一集节目，
have found ourselves staring at a wall or completely blanking in a conversation because we are too absorbed in trying to think over our emotions or our actions or some experience or what we're going to do next. That can be really alienating and isolating, but it also reduces not only our enjoyment of life, but also our ability to really connect
都会发现自己盯着墙发呆，或者在对话中彻底大脑空白，因为我们太沉迷于试图反复思考我们的情绪、行动、某种经历或接下来要做什么。这可能会非常具有疏离感和孤立感，但它不仅会降低我们对生活的享受，还会降低我们真正与坐在对面的人建立连接的能力
with the person sitting across from us. There's also the addition. consequences that arise from extreme public or external self-awareness. And I know we've spoken a little bit about social anxiety, but I want to dive into that further. When we have very high public self-awareness, often that can make us really charismatic. It can make us really agreeable and friendly, which is all incredible, incredible traits to have. But also, we tend to focus more on how other people view us in certain situations than doing what makes us happy, or acting in a manner that is aligned with our true selves,
此外还有一些额外的后果。极端公众或外部自我觉察所带来的后果。我知道我们已经稍微谈过社交焦虑了，但我想对此作进一步探讨。当我们拥有非常高的公众 self-awareness 时，通常这会让我们极具个人魅力。它会让我们非常随和、友好，这全都是令人难以置信的优良特质。但同时，我们在某些情况下往往更专注于别人如何看待我们，而不是去做那些让我们快乐的事，或者做出符合我们真实自我的行为，
our authentic selves, mainly out of this fear of being judged and a heightened acknowledgement of other people's perceptions at the end of the day. So as a result, we tend to stick to group norms, we try to avoid situations in which we might embarrass ourselves or step out of line, and we take less risks, even though, like we said before, it's unlikely that anyone is even noticing. So that external self-awareness, it can lead to evaluation anxiety in which we become distressed, anxious, worried about the opinions of others, and put a lot more importance on them. therefore almost becoming quite hypervigilant in social situations, less authentic, enjoying ourselves less, and also sometimes even leading to the development of things like a social anxiety disorder.
我们的本真自我，这主要是出于对被评判的恐惧，以及归根结底对他人看法的强烈认知。因此，我们往往墨守成规，试图避开那些可能会让自己出丑或出格的情境，冒更少的风险，尽管正如我们之前所说的那样，其实根本没人注意到。因此，这种外部自我觉察会导致评估焦虑，在这种焦虑中，我们会对别人的意见感到痛苦、焦虑、担忧，并赋予它们过多的重要性。因此，在社交场合中往往变得高度警惕，不那么真实，对自己的享受减少，有时甚至会导致社交焦虑障碍等问题的产生。
So we have that additional component, that social component, and then sometimes there's a reality that we are not going to have the answers for everything. Some emotions will just emerge spontaneously with no reason. Sometimes we are irrational creatures and we act in ways that we don't really necessarily need an explanation for. Hyper-intellectualizing or rationalizing everything may mean that life actually becomes almost too complex for us to actually enjoy it. And we kind of also become that, you know, annoying person at the party, as I have been many times, who really needs to psychoanalyze everything, you know, everything that we're doing, everything that other are doing, rather than just being there, rather than just having fun, it's not always going to make
所以我们有了这个额外的组成部分，这个社交组成部分，然后有时还有一个现实，那就是我们不可能对所有事情都有答案。有些情绪会自发涌现，没有任何理由。有时我们是不理性的生物，我们的行事方式并不一定都需要一个解释。过度知识化或合理化一切，可能意味着生活实际上变得过于复杂，以至于我们无法真正享受它。而且我们某种程度上也会变成那种，你知道的，派对上讨人嫌的人——就像我曾经多次做过的那样——非常需要对一切进行心理分析，你知道的，对我们所做的每一件事、别人做的每一件事都进行分析，而不是仅仅身处其中，而不是仅仅去享受乐趣，这并不总是能
you someone's favorite person to hang out with. It's not always actually going to make you happier either. So we've kind of outlined some of the risks, some of the ways to discern whether you are perhaps too self-aware. So why does this happen? Where does this come from? Why are some of us bordering kind of on the precipice of dangerous territory here? I think it's a really interesting interaction between quite a few things and one of the main culprits, and I know I'll be stabbing myself in the back here, but it's consuming too much self-help content. And not just that, but also contradictory self-help content. So what I want to discuss next is some of the reasons, the origins, explanations for why we
让你成为别人最喜欢交往的人。它也并不总是真的能让你更快乐。因此，我们已经勾勒出了一些风险，以及辨别你是否可能过于自我觉察的一些方法。那么为什么会这样？这从何而来？为什么我们中的一些人会徘徊在危险地带的边缘？我认为这是相当多的事物之间非常有趣的相互作用，而主要的罪魁祸首之一——我知道我这是在搬起石头砸自己的脚——就是消费了太多的自我提升内容。不仅如此，还有相互矛盾的自我提升内容。因此，接下来我要讨论的一些原因、起源、解释，解释了为什么我们
have become perhaps too self-aware, some of the other arguments that maybe we aren't even at that point yet where we could be gaining more knowledge about ourselves, so much more, all of that, and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts. and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
变得可能过于自我觉察，还有一些其他的论点认为，也许我们甚至还没有达到那个可以从自己身上获得更多知识的地步，还有更多内容，在短暂的休息之后为您揭晓。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个陌生的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家进行对话。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-E-Rashire. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
还有更多内容，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即T-W-O-P-C-E-N-T，可在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要去招惹乡下女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要去招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德，在《女友们》的这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个多产的骗子。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友s》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross Double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉姬·金姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉姬·金姆有什么见鬼的关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point
在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，回顾当时的发生过的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道，我的意思是，在这一点上，
Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence
马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集节目，所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。所以，谢谢你把那句话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah For me it's one of the most important years for black people In American history Listen to look back at it
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。收听《Look Back at It》
On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们还在继续追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的博弈。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要，还是说你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app,
绝对是。这也是两个不同的信任层级。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio App，
Search learn the hard way and listen now. So we're going to explore a few reasons why we can kind of tip over to the extreme of the self-awareness spectrum continuum, whatever you would like to call it. Now, I want to make a quick disclaimer here. I am in no ways advocating for you to go and chuck out all of your self-help books that you spent really good money on, or to quit therapy or to never examine your feelings. I think that's totally against my ethos and highly unethical to suggest. But what I do want to explore is how can we become more balanced such that we can still have a bit of surprise in our life, live in the moment, and have an authentic human experience without being tied up by our thoughts. And also having that level of self-understanding that makes life just that little bit easier.
搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。因此，我们将探讨一些原因，为什么我们会倾向于滑向自我觉察光谱、连续体——无论你愿意怎么称呼它——的极端。现在，我想在这里做一个快速的声明：我绝不是在倡导你去扔掉所有你花了大价钱买的自助书籍，或者放弃治疗，或者永远不去审视自己的感受。我认为这完全违背了我的精神内核，而且这种建议是非常不道德的。但我想探讨的是，我们如何才能变得更加平衡，这样我们仍然可以在生活中拥有一点惊喜、活在当下，并拥有真实的人类体验，而不会被自己的思想所羁绊。同时也拥有那种让生活变得稍微轻松一点的自我理解水平。
So let's kind of look at where this comes from. The first explanation has to do with overthinking and a high degree of perfectionism, which is a personality trait. This has also interestingly been linked in numerous studies to a higher IQ. So if you are someone who is highly intelligent, the chances that you are also highly self-aware is going to be pretty high. So the hypothesis or the logic kind of follows that people who are more intelligent, they have a greater propensity for self-examination, and self-reflection, which can make them more prone to things like overthinking, or the reverse relationship, people with a high IQ spend more time overthinking
所以让我们来看看这究竟源于何处。第一个解释与过度思考和高度的完美主义有关，这是一种人格特质。有趣的是，众多研究还将这与更高的智商联系起来。因此，如果你是一个智商很高的人，你同时也高度自我觉察几率会相当高。因此，假设或逻辑是这样的：更聪明的人对自我审视和自我反省有更大的倾向，这会使他们更容易倾向于过度思考；或者反过来，高智商的人花更多时间过度思考，
and therefore naturally have a greater level of self-awareness. So it is the overthinking that makes them more intelligent both in a traditional way, but also in an emotional way as well. So overthinking occurs when we repeatedly dwell or worry about the same thing, the same event, the same thought for an extended period of time. Like, you know, did I say something that was embarrassing? That is a sign of high public self-awareness or why am I feeling so upset or sad? Why am I not over this by now? That would be a high private self-awareness. However, I think the fallacy of overthinking and as a result this high level of self-awareness is that we kind of convince ourselves
因此自然而然地拥有更高水平的自我觉察。所以正是过度思考使他们在传统意义上以及在情感意义上都变得更聪明。因此，当我们长时间反复琢磨或担忧同一件事情、同一个事件、同一个想法时，就会发生过度思考。比如，“我是不是说了什么让人尴尬的话？”这是高度公众自我觉察的迹象，或者“为什么我感到如此难过或悲伤？为什么到现在我还没走出来？”这将是高度私人自我觉察的体现。然而，我认为过度思考的谬论以及由此产生的高水平自我觉察在于，我们某种程度上说服了自己，
that thinking about something repeatedly will mean that we are better able to solve the problem, or that we are somehow, with all of this mulling over and, you know, reflection and introspection, that we're going to find some hidden answer that we hadn't previously considered. We use overthinking almost as a way to self-soothe or regulate our emotions, but also to minimize anxiety in the short term because overthinking, as we know, know, gives us what we call an illusion of control. However, it can also be incredibly mentally exhausting. And contrary to what we expect, it concludes us to fall into a pattern known as analysis paralysis, whereby the more we think about a problem or a situation, the less clear a solution actually
反复思考某事意味着我们能够更好地解决问题，或者通过这一切的深思熟虑、反思和内省，我们将会找到一些以前没有考虑过的隐藏答案。我们几乎把过度思考当作一种自我安抚或调节情绪的方式，同时也为了在短期内将焦虑降到最低，因为我们知道，过度思考会给我们带来我们所谓的“控制的错觉”。然而，它也可能在精神上令人筋疲力竭。与我们的预期相反，它会让我们陷入一种被称为“分析瘫痪”的模式，即我们对问题或情况思考得越多，解决方案实际上就变得越不清晰。自我觉察、过度思考和完美主义之间也存在着相当紧密的联系。所以完美主义发生在当我们为自己设定了难以置信的高标准时，这些标准有时极具挑战性，几乎不可能达到。
becomes. There's also a pretty strong link between self-awareness, overthinking and then perfectionism. So a perfectionism occurs when we set incredibly high standards for ourselves that are at times extremely difficult, almost impossible to meet. And we also feel an accompanying sense of self-doubt and shame and also blame when we feel that we cannot meet our own personal expectations. When you are highly self-aware, you are often more attuned to your failures and the ways in which perhaps your actions may not be aligned with your intentions. And so you set increasingly higher goals and standards for yourself and then you are constantly reflecting on how to achieve them and you are highly aware of what happens when you don't. You feel the emotional consequences of that so deeply because
当我们觉得无法达到自己的个人期望时，我们也会伴随着一种自我怀疑、羞耻感以及责备感。当你高度自我觉察时，你通常对自己的失败以及你的行动可能与你的意图不一致的方式更加敏锐。因此，你为自己设定了越来越高的目标和标准，然后你不断反思如何实现它们，并且高度意识到当你做不到时会发生什么。你对那种情况带来的情感后果体会得如此深刻，因为
you are not someone who can step away from a hard feeling. You are not someone who can encounter something like failure and not examine the causes, the effects, everything that kind of exists in that ecosystem. I also read this really interesting article whilst I was researching this that explained how people who were only children growing up are also more likely to have that higher propensity to spend a lot of time self-examining. And when we think about the logic and context behind this, that makes a lot of sense. Firstly, most only children, They didn't have other children around the house to play with and interact with and to create little games together.
你不是那种能够从痛苦感受中抽身离开的人。你不是那种能够遭遇像失败这样的事情而不去检查其原因、影响以及存在于该生态系统中的一切的人。我在做这项研究时还读到了一篇非常有趣的文章，它解释了独生子女在成长过程中也更有可能拥有花大量时间进行自我审视的更高倾向。当我们思考这背后的逻辑和背景时，这就非常合乎情理了。首先，大多数独生子女，他们身边没有其他孩子可以一起玩耍、互动和创造小游戏。
So they kind of had to become really good at self-intertaining and spending a lot of time with their own thoughts. They also probably spend a lot more time around adults. Their parents, for one, but then also their parents' friends or colleagues. And so they gain a lot of those reasoning skills a lot earlier. They perhaps are quicker to intellectual. And that makes it more likely that they will apply those cognitive skills not only at an earlier age, but with more frequency because of that alone time, leading to a high degree of self-awareness,
所以他们不得不非常擅长自娱自乐，并花大量时间与自己的思维相处。他们可能也花更多时间与成年人在一起。一方面是他们的父母，然后还有父母的朋友或同事。因此，他们很早就掌握了许多推理技能。他们或许能更快地理解事物。这使得他们不仅在更早的年龄，而且会更频繁地运用这些认知技能，仅仅是因为拥有这些独处时间，从而导致高度的自我意识，
not just as a child, but then again, as an adult. But then there's this final, almost cultural, societal explanation that I think we really need to discuss. And like I said before, I'm kind of undermining my own authority by discussing this, but I also think it's important because the increasing consumption of self-help content, I think may actually be causing us to not be as present at times, or to be constantly bombarded about messaging across social media in our friendships, relationships, even the workplace, that we need to spend a lot more time in our own thoughts and perhaps getting into psychological practices that may not actually be that evidence-based or that fruitful. And in many ways, that is important, right?
不仅是在童年时期，在成年后也是如此。但还有一个最终的、几乎是文化和社会的解释，我认为我们真的需要讨论它。就像我之前说的，讨论这个其实是在削弱我自己的权威，但我同时也认为这很重要，因为不断消费自助内容，实际上可能会导致我们在某些时候无法专注当下，或者在社交媒体、友谊、关系甚至职场中不断受到信息的狂轰滥炸，我们需要花更多的时间在自己的思考中，或许还会接触一些实际上并不那么基于证据或那么有成效的心理实践。在许多方面，这很重要，对吧？
Being more in touch with our emotions is important. Having any kind of exposure to clinical work, therapy, psychology. I think that is so valuable, especially in the last few decades. You know, we've seen these enormous strides towards normalising not only conversations around mental health and mental illness, but just emotional well-being in general, which I think is a huge change from the environment we would have encountered some 50 years ago, where talking about your feelings, examining your behaviours, looking for internal explanations, was seen as quite odd, was almost stigmatised or made you the weird person. in town. And you know, I grew up and I still live in Australia and even these days when you travel to some rural or regional areas, there's still this really big taboo around speaking about your feelings. Things like journaling or therapy or mindfulness or meditation, they're just seen as quote unquote and I think completely factually incorrect, but they're seen as weak. They're seen as quite
更好地了解自己的情绪很重要。接触任何形式的临床工作、治疗、心理学。我认为这非常有价值，特别是在过去的几十年里。你知道，我们已经看到在将关于心理健康和精神疾病的对话正常化方面取得了巨大的进步，而且不仅仅是这些，还包括一般的精神福祉，我认为这与我们大约50年前遇到的环境发生了巨大的变化，当时谈论你的感受、审视你的行为、寻找内在的解释被认为是相当怪异的，几乎被污名化，或者会让你成为镇上的怪人。而且你知道，我是在澳大利亚长大的，现在仍然住在那里，甚至在今天，当你去一些农村或地区时，对于谈论你的感受仍然存在着非常大的禁忌。像写日记、治疗、正念或冥想这样的事情，它们只被称为“引号内”的内容，我认为这完全是不符合事实的，但它们被认为是软弱的。它们被视为相当
strange. And so we've attempted to really counter this by normalizing how we approach how we're feeling and the when, the where, the why, the how, normalizing understanding yourself better. That, of course, that movement has really trickled and filtered into the fast media that we're consuming. There are hundreds, if not thousands of creators and public figures and social media accounts who have really popularized and tried to make mental health content a lot more accessible. And that is wonderful. But how do we know that what we are kind of consuming is a real or be actually helpful? I think you can kind of find, you know, a podcast or an Instagram real or a TikTok about literally anything you're going through. And someone, people like myself, we are going to
奇怪的。因此，我们试图通过将我们对感受的处理方式以及何时、何地、为什么、如何进行正常化，来真正对抗这种现象，将更好地理解自己正常化。当然，这种运动确实已经渗透并过滤到了我们正在消费的快速媒体中。有成百上千甚至数千名创作者、公众人物和社交媒体账号，真正普及并试图让心理健康内容变得更加容易获得。这太棒了。但是我们怎么知道我们正在消费的东西是真实的还是真的有帮助的呢？我想你可以找到一个播客，或者一个Instagram短视频，或者一个关于你正在经历的字面任何事情的TikTok。而某个人，像我这样的人，我们会
give you an explanation for exactly why you're feeling a certain way. And whilst I don't want to deny that that is really, really useful and valuable, obviously that's why I'm doing it. I see that is really purposeful and important. I think the issue arises at three major times. Firstly, when the advice or the information we're receiving is contradictory. So one person is telling you to do one thing, another person is telling you to do another. Secondly, when it's inaccurate or the information that we're consuming is not exactly scientific, I think that happens all the time where people are going to try and give you a simple explanation for something that, and it's not actually correct, and that can leave us feeling more confused. And then finally, when we can't separate our reality from looking
给你解释你为什么会有某种特定的感受。虽然我不想否认这真的是非常有用和有价值的，显然这就是我这样做的原因。我认为这真的很有目的性和重要性。我认为问题出现在三个主要时刻。首先，当我们接受的建议或信息相互矛盾时。所以一个人叫你做一件事，另一个人叫你做另一件事。其次，当它不准确或我们正在消费的信息并不完全符合科学时，我认为这种情况经常发生，人们试图给你一个简单的解释，而这其实并不正确，这会让我们感到更加困惑。最后，当我们无法将现实与寻找
for an internal explanation. this is when we fall into the trap of being too self-aware to the point where we really can't escape the tendency to overthink and excessively self-examine. And I think worse, if we have been provided with the wrong information, sometimes the conclusion that we're going to reach is incorrect. And that's just going to leave us more stuck, more confused, and in some ways spiraling. Also, I think, let's be honest here, it can be incredibly. mentally draining to be completely self-aware of your existence and your actions and how other people perceive you at all times and even quite existential to feel like everything you do needs to have a
内在解释分离开来时。这就是我们陷入过度自我意识陷阱的时候，以至于我们真的无法摆脱过度思考和过度自我审视的倾向。我认为更糟糕的是，如果我们被提供了错误的信息，有时我们得出的结论是不正确的。这只会让我们更加困惑，更加迷茫，甚至在某种程度上陷入恶性循环。同时，我认为，老实说，要时刻完全意识到自己的存在、自己的行动以及其他人如何看待你，在精神上会令人筋疲力尽，甚至相当具有存在主义色彩，感觉你所做的每一件事都需要有一个
reason or be aligned with some version of yourself. It is a very delicate balancing act. But like I said before, there is something to be said for the occasional moment of ignorance and the opportunity to just be free of your thoughts and enjoy your life for what it is. So how do we go about striking that balance? We do not want to give up our self-awareness. We don't want to be someone who is completely unconscious of how we behave or who we are, but also we want to be able to actually enjoy our lives. I think, firstly, we have to recognize when we are overthinking or self-examining,
理由，或者与某种版本的自我保持一致。这是一个非常微妙的平衡。但就像我之前说的，偶尔的无知时刻以及有机会摆脱你的思绪并享受生活的本来面目，也是有其道理的。那么我们该如何达成这种平衡呢？我们不想放弃我们的自我意识。我们不想成为一个完全不了解自己行为或身份的人，但同时也希望能够真正享受生活。我认为，首先，我们必须认识到自己什么时候在过度思考或自我审视，
perhaps excessively and the reason why that is, is the thing that you're thinking about necessary for you to become a better person or to feel more like yourself or are you just using this as a coping strategy to perhaps actually avoid feeling your emotions and just staying with them until they pass. I think be really conscious of whether the practices that you are partaking in, are they actually making you feel better or are they just getting you more and more stuck in a bit of a cycle, less and less connected with who you really are? Secondly, I would say, be conscious of the media that you are consuming, whether or not it is actually sound information. That is something that I think is really crucial, because the thing about social media that I think
也许是过度地，其原因在于，你所思考的事情对于你成为一个更好的人或感觉更像你自己来说是必要的吗？或者你只是把这当作一种应对策略，实际上是为了逃避去感受你的情绪，并任由它们停留直到消散？我认为要真正意识到你所参与的实践是否真的让你感觉更好，或者它们只是让你越来越陷入某种循环中，与真实的自己越来越疏离？其次，我想说，要注意你所消费的媒体，它是否真的是可靠的信息。我认为这至关重要，因为关于社交媒体的一点是
we all kind of implicitly know, but not many people really speak on, is that anytime you view something, especially from a content creator, those views are engagement and engagement is money. So people are trying to get your attention. And sometimes the thing that is most correct, logical, has the most evidence, is not going to be the most popular. So you really have to make sure that what we are looking at, what we are consuming is factual. I think also sometimes we can become almost like emotional hypercontriacs where we need to Google and examine every little thought to determine whether it's healthy, unhealthy, useful, not useful. And honestly, I'm kind of of the opinion that every emotion has a purpose. No emotion is inherently bad. It's just what happens when you let that emotion
我们其实都心知肚明，但没有多少人真正说出来，那就是任何时候你观看某些内容，特别是来自内容创作者的内容，这些观看量就是互动，而互动就是金钱.所以人们在试图吸引你的注意力。有时最正确、最合乎逻辑、最有证据支持的事情，并不是最受欢迎的。所以你真的必须确保我们所看的、所消费的是基于事实的。我也认为有时我们几乎会变成情绪上的疑病症患者，我们需要谷歌搜索并审视每一个小小的想法，以确定它是否健康、不健康、有用还是无用。老实说，我的看法是每种情绪都有其目的。没有哪种情绪天生就是坏的。坏的是当你让这种情绪
control you. Your emotions are just there to tell you something about how you're feeling. They are not there to be your whole reality, right? They are not always going to be correct. So I think don't let the need for self-awareness minimize what you're going through. If you've had a particularly hard week, it's okay to be upset and angry and not need to integrate that right away. In fact, I think it's probably better for you mentally to have an emotional outlet at times that doesn't feel entirely rational. We also know that overthinking and with that excessive self-awareness has a very deep relationship and a strong correlation to anxiety. So finding ways to manage your anxiety and your stress, it may also allow you to better regulate the amount of time you spend in your own.
控制了你时发生的事情。你的情绪只是为了告诉你一些关于你感受的事情。它们不是为了成为你的全部现实，对吧？它们并不总是正确的。所以我认为不要让对自我意识的需求贬低你正在经历的事情。如果你度过了特别艰难的一周，感到沮丧和生气是可以的，不需要马上将其整合。事实上，我认为偶尔有一个并不完全理性的情绪宣泄口，对你的心理健康可能更好。我们也知道，过度思考以及伴随而来的过度自我意识与焦虑有着非常深厚的关系和强烈的相关性。因此，找到管理焦虑和压力的方法，也可能让你更好地调节自己沉浸在思维中的时间，
thoughts and not let that time get in the way of other meaningful, important things. One thing I like to do for myself is just give myself 20 minutes every day to feel really worried about something or to feel anxious about the things that are on my mind. 20 minutes to just let myself process what's been going on in my life, potential explanations for my behavior where I feel like I fit in relation to others or in relation to to my environment. And in that moment, I'm not suppressing that feeling. I'm not ignoring that feeling. What I'm doing is acknowledging it and recognizing it's part of my life, but also containing it to just one part of my day so that it's manageable. Honestly, I want to say it just one more
并且不让这些时间妨碍其他有意义的重要事情。我喜欢为自己做的一件事就是每天给自己20分钟，去真正为某事感到担忧，或者为心中的事情感到焦虑。花20分钟让自己去处理生活中发生的事情，寻找我行为的潜在解释，找出我在人际关系或环境中感觉自己处于什么位置。在那一刻，我没有压抑这种感觉。我没有忽视这种感觉。我所做的是承认它，并认识到它是生活的一部分，但同时也把它限制在我一天的某个特定部分，以便它是可控的。老实说，我想再讲最后
time here. Self-awareness is not a bad thing. And I think it is highly subjective when our level of self-awareness has perhaps become harmful. So please just use this as a guide or even as a thought exercise, if nothing else, and come to your own conclusions. Do you actually think it's possible to be too self-aware? And if you have a different answer or if you agree with me, let me know. I would honestly love to hear it. I don't think that there has been enough research into this in the broader psychology space, but I think it's going to be really interesting to see how, this trend might develop over time and how we might see kind of a separation between different groups in society, one group who has had access to this information and who is reaching these
一次。自我意识并不是一件坏事。而且我认为我们的自我意识水平在什么时候变得有害，这具有高度的主观性。所以请把这仅仅当作一个指南，甚至仅仅作为一个思维练习，然后得出你自己的结论。你真的认为人有可能过度自我意识吗？如果你有不同的答案或者同意我的观点，请告诉我。我真的很想听到。我认为在更广泛的心理学领域，对这方面的研究还不够，但我觉得观察这种趋势随时间如何发展，以及我们如何看到社会中不同群体之间的某种分离，将会非常有趣，其中一个群体有机会接触到这些信息并达到了
high levels of introspection and self-consciousness, and then other people who might not be as accepting of some of these theories and ideas, and how that difference kind of manifests in our lives. So I think it's super interesting. I would love to hear your thoughts if you don't already follow me on Instagram. It is at That Psychology Podcast. So follow me over there. Shoot me a DM if you have an opinion. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to give it a five-star review wherever you are listening. I know that I say this all the time, but it still stands true. I read every single one of your reviews. I read every single one of your DMs. And it's really honestly mind-blowing. Honestly, how many of you are out there?
高度的内省和自我意识，而另群体可能不那么接受其中的一些理论和思想，这种差异如何在我们的生活中体现出来。所以我认为这超级有趣。如果你还没有在Instagram上关注我，我很乐意听到你的想法。账号是 That Psychology Podcast。去那里关注我吧。如果你有任何意见，给我发私信。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在你收听的地方给它一个五星好评。我知道我一直在这么说，但它依然真实。我阅读了你们的每一条评论。我阅读了你们的每一条私信。老实说，这真的很震撼。老实说，你们有多少人
all the different countries that you're from, this community is just insanely cool. So thank you so much for following along and supporting me. I really hope you enjoyed this episode and we will be back next week with another one. Two percent. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T.W.O.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
来自所有不同的国家，这个社区简直酷毙了。非常感谢你们的关注和支持。我真的希望你们喜欢这一集，我们下周会带着新的一集回归。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T.W.O.%。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're, you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方都真的不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marncini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
网络侦探大军花了很长时间才揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。